this is supposed to tell us who the love
of our life is based on cheese
hello everyone I'm Philippa Sue and I
play Emma in one true loves now in our
film Emma has to choose between her two
true loves one being Jesse played by
Luke and the other being Sam play bye
let's take this quiz to find out who we
would be with oh what a mystery I can't
wait let's find out
done question the first plan your dream
first date between a movie night concert
afternoon picnic bar hopping trying a
new restaurant for a spontaneous road
trip a road trip is just you're
committing to a lot of time whereas I
feel like a movie night is like that's
too little time but maybe sometimes
that's for the best
okay I'm gonna go with trying a new
restaurant
um
I think a concert or bar hoping because
you've got options there yeah you have
an external stimuli that's maybe
bringing up conversation points you go
to a really good concert it's like and
then you come back like oh that was
great but was it great was it great
because of the person that you took or
was it great because the concert was
really good the music was good or the
movie that you watched was good next you
pick some cheese to eat with your love I
mean and go to breathe you've got a blue
you've got some mozzarella oh and then
there's no cheese for me a Manchego a
goat and then no cheese for me boss this
is supposed to tell us who the love of
our life is based on cheese what are you
guys gonna do I'm gonna go maybe I think
maybe Brie or mozzarella I what are you
gonna do I'm gonna go with Manchego
because
it's just delicious it's just always
delicious well how nice of YouTube Just
because it's easy to
yeah it's not too messy
choose a Nook to read in we have a
picture of a hammock we have a soft sofa
couch we have a lady in a wooden some
would say an adult's cubby house we have
some Woolen socks and a blanket in front
of the fire we have a lady in some kind
of Mediterranean
Atrium type thing with some plants and
we have an outdoor hammock as well again
you describe that perfectly I would have
been like
a hammock I'm gonna go with cozy fire
cozy socks I might steer away from that
just because I know that that is so cozy
that I would instantly policy yeah there
is no way I'm getting through whatever
I'm gonna say the the very first picture
it's like it's your you know it looks
like a backyard but it's very green it's
very Lush you can go inside if you want
you can go inside if you get too cold
get too hot yes I think I'm gonna take
um Mediterranean European looking Atrium
Greenery
um what is your favorite type of Novel
to read is it a romance a thriller a
mystery historical fiction science
fiction I know this straight away I'm
gonna go historical fiction slash
nonfiction I'm a historical fiction
person too well how nice of you two just
based on everything that I've read in
the past yeah I'm gonna out myself I'm
gonna expose myself I'm a massive nerd
and so I love reading like hard sci-fi
so sci-fi guy um I would say I would say
sci-fi
your first fight as a couple will be
about where to eat what to watch where
to travel to money whose turn it is to
do the dishes fight never I I love I
love the idea that a couple would fight
about what to watch or where to eat I
think that's really really sweet so I
would probably go one or the other I
feel like it's the dishes for me really
yeah I would say what to watch I can be
very opinionated about what I what I
what I put on the TV and sometimes I
really feel like trashy reality
television and sometimes I really don't
feel like tragic reality yeah I'm gonna
go what to watch as well
how does that see see how does it feel
to be left out
I feel special
which dessert will you share ice cream
ice cream number one shaved ice number
two chocolate cake number three cookies
number four
apple pie number five berries and cream
exclamation three exclamation points I'm
between cook cookies and berries for me
I think it's kind of cute to share an
ice cream you know I'm actually I'm
gonna say shaved ice I'm gonna say
shaved ice I have had shaved ice quite a
bit I love it I think it's just like
such a it's such a it's such a cold uh
surprise lots of textures and and it's
always fun I'm going with ice cream
there you go I'm gonna have berries and
cream at the exclamation marks oh I like
this next one choose a pet to adopt with
your one true love we've got a little
budgerigar a budgeriga that very that
specific verb I'd call that a badger
yoga I think we call it a budgie um
we've got a terribly blue-eyed kitten
got a hamster we've got a little yeah
totally I had a hamster growing up
goldfish a dog with a tennis ball and
what looks like a community yeah I think
the answer is pretty obvious for me
you've got it done I've got a dog and
look at that face with the tennis ball
oh my gosh yeah yep doggo cat for me I
think
um I think we're all going dog maybe dog
yeah
all right finally which house will you
live happily ever after in we have this
modern lake house we have what looks
like but maybe like in a city somewhere
it looks guys on the street we've got
our front porch yeah
an Irish like a stone Stone House we've
got a castle a literal castle and then
we've got a very like slake motor cool
Modern Pool I think that would go over
the lake I'm gonna go the Old Stone
country Homestead I can see like a
little bit of acreage around
maybe a fruit tree or two I think I'm
gonna go for the LA modern
kind of reminds me of my house I'm gonna
go with the Stony house
where are you okay where are your
answers
well folks
we have all ended up with Jesse you'll
end up with Jesse your high school
sweetheart it was a difficult decision
to make but ultimately a life of
adventures with your husband is what
you're looking for and even though you
had grieved the loss of him you're ready
to start over again where where is the
science behind Okay I need to be a Sam
advocate for a second here look I'm I'm
gonna do this quiz again I'm gonna do it
again I'm gonna what what does it take
to get a Sam answer because because I
don't think you're being very fair to
Sam right now if you want to see who you
would end up with click the link below
even though it's rigged even though it's
rigged and you're probably gonna get
Jesse because we all got Jessie even
though we answered completely different
and we'll see who the f made this quiz
[Music]